[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts I
want to talk about chat GPT
you may have heard of chat GPT it's a
popular online chat spot which is Powers
by artificial intelligence chat GPT chat
gbt chat GPT the Revolutionary new
language model developed by open AI have
you experimented with it I have not
basically AI is replacing human function
even shows like this will be replaced by
some type of chatbot some type of Angry
Irish AI the artificial intelligence
program chat gbt has been hot in the
streets as of late many people are
already using the free AI chatbot to do
research and write essays and some even
fear that chat gbt could replace a need
for human beings to be working a lot of
jobs in the near future which got me
thinking could artificial intelligence
ever take the place of comedians in
today's video I'll be feeding Chachi BT
a series of prompts from some of our
favorite comedians asking the artificial
intelligence program to reread write
jokes in that comedic style now for this
to fully work it's important to pick
three Comics that have unique and
distinct voices so today we'll be
focusing in on AI replicating Joey Diaz
Bobby Lee and of course theovan first up
we got Bobby Lee all right let's see
what happens I'm just going to type in
tell me a joke in the style of Comedian
Bobby Lee
sure here's a joke in the style of Bobby
Lee so I was at the airport the other
day right and I saw a sign that said
airport security and unlike security
more like scared ID I mean I've had
better security from a screen door you
know what I'm saying okay uh that was
pretty random I guess it's something
Bobby might say I don't really know I
think this might work better if we get
specific and ask chat gbt to tell us
exact stories in the style of Bobby Lee
I'm going to type in tell me a funny
story in the comedic styling of Bobby
Lee about Bobby wanting his
ex-girlfriend to move out of his house
okay here's the story Bobby Lee was
living with his girlfriend but things
just weren't working out he was ready
for her to move out but she wasn't
budging every time he brought up the
subject she had an excuse one day Bobby
had enough and decided to get creative
he dressed up as a ghost and started
making spooky noises and knocking over
pictures in the house his girlfriend was
so scared that she finally agreed to
move out however a few days later his
girlfriend returned moving all her
things back in and declaring that she
wasn't afraid of a silly ghost Bobby was
back to square one but he didn't have a
good story to tell on stage he regaled
the audience with his fail ghost stunt
which had everyone in stitches Bobby
proved that even when things aren't
going your way a sense of humor could
always save the day I could see Bobby
saying that that was pretty good I think
the key here is going to be to ask his
story so moving on to Joey Diaz we're
learning a little bit about how this
program works next up we got Joey Diaz
Joey Diaz Facebook Twitter check
yourself before you wreck yourself big
dicks in your ass
I already have a feeling Chachi BT's
gonna have a hard time with this one not
even artificial intelligence could come
up with some of the vulgar [__] that's
going on in between Joey Diaz's ears we
gotta get specific though we learned
that at let's go tell me a story from
the point of view of Joey Diaz POV
talking to Joe Rogan on his podcast
about living in Boulder Colorado and
getting into some trouble
Joe Rogan and Joey teals are sitting
down for a conversation on Joe's podcast
Joe hey Joey great to have you here
today I heard you recently spent some
time in Boulder Colorado how was that
experience for you Joey Hey Joe great to
see you too yeah I went to Boulder for a
vacation but things definitely didn't go
as planned Joe really what happened Joey
well first of all let me tell you about
the drivers in Boulder they're like
nothing I've ever seen before they park
on the sidewalks and ride their bikes on
the freeway it's crazy Joe that sounds
intense so what kind of trouble did you
get into while you were there Joey so I
went to a dispensary to buy some weed
and I think they must have put something
extra in there because it was a wild
ride I started seeing bright colors and
lights everywhere and I needed to clear
my head so I went for a walk and ended
up at a drum circle in the park Joe that
sounds like a wild experience Joey yeah
it was I started playing the drums and
before I knew it I was leading a hooray
down the street people were following me
and dancing it was just the craziest
thing Joe I bet you were having the time
of your life Joey oh for sure I'll never
forget that day but let's just say I
learned my lesson and stayed away from
the dispensaries for the rest of my stay
in Boulder Joe laughs I can understand
that Joey it's always a great time
having you on the show and hearing your
crazy stories dude this is so funny
because that actually sounded like stuff
Joey Diaz might say on The Joe Rogan
Experience it's just like one step off
like it's just still a little bit
robotic but it's closer than I really
expected honestly it also just needs to
end every sentence saying Joe Rogan and
then it'd definitely be just like Joey
Diaz I'd say it's better at Uncle Joey
than it is at Bobby Lee so far but now
it's time for chat gbt's ultimate test
can it replicate the most unique brain
in all of Comedy Theo Von gangs giving
son I feel like I'm slowly getting the
hang of how to use this thing throughout
the course of this video definitely you
have to be more specific in the prompt
if you want a better response so to wrap
this up let's ask it three questions
about theovan's life and we'll be real
specific with things that we've heard
him say on his podcast before start off
tell me a funny story in the comedic
stylings of Theo Von about growing up in
the South and wetting the bed all right
here's a story in the comedic styling of
Theo found about growing up in the south
and wetting the bed so I grew up down in
the South and let me tell you it was a
different time we didn't have fancy
things like waterproof mattresses or
those plastic mattress protectors we
just had a good old-fashioned cotton
sheet and being a southern boy I was
raised to always wear my big boy pants
you know what I mean so when I hit the
age of nine or ten I was already pretty
damn confident but then one night I had
a little accident I woke up in a puddle
of my own making and let me tell you it
was a humbling experience but you know
what they say when life gives you lemons
make sweet tea and that's exactly what I
did I got up changed my sheets and
poured myself a big glass of sweet tea
and you know what I was back in my big
pants in no time from that day on I
learned that accidents happen but it's
how you handle them that defines you as
a person and let me tell you I've been
handling those bedwetting accidents with
a big old glass of sweetie ever since
dude this is really good that one was
[__] perfect all right what should we
do next tell me a funny story in the
comedic stylings of Theo Vaughn about
being a kid in the South trying to sell
tattooed hamsters to people after
they attended concerts all right here's
a story in the comedic styling of Theo
found about being a kid growing up in
the South and trying to sell tattooed
hamsters to people as they left a
concert so I was this kid growing up in
the South always on the lookout for a
good hustle and one day I heard that a
big concert was coming to town I knew
this was my chance to make some real
money so I hatched a plan I got old of
some hamsters and with the help of my
cousin who was an amateur tattoo artist
I started tattooing these little
critters with all sorts of designs I
mean who would want a hamster with a
tattoo of their favorite band right so
the day of the concert arrives and I set
up shop outside the venue and let me
tell you I was getting some serious
interest people were actually stopping
to take a look at these little tattooed
hamsters but then something unexpected
happened one of the hamsters managed to
escape and ran right onto the stage
during the concert the crowd went wild
and before I knew it the hamster had
become a star I quickly realized that I
had made a grave mistake these hamsters
were worthwhite more as concert
performers than they were as Pastor
Critters so I shut down my stand and
became the manager for these little
tattooed hamsters we went on tour and
let me tell you it was wild ride I never
made it big in the music business but
those hamsters sure did and I always
look back on that crazy day outside the
concert venue with a smile on my face it
just goes to show you that sometimes the
most unexpected things can lead to the
biggest opportunities this is so good
dude he uses like man and like if you
think about it in his voice instead of
like a robot voice this is insane this
is kind of creepy honestly all right
last one let's see let's see create a
fake conversation between comedians Theo
Vaughn and Bobby Lee that takes place on
Theo's podcast this past weekend make
the conversation funny and about Bobby
not having much lucks on the dating apps
welcome to the show Bobby it's great to
have you here today Bobby Lee thanks for
having me Theo I'm always down for a
good time on your podcast Theo Von so
Bobby I hear you've been having a Rocco
on The Dating after lately what's been
going on Bobby Lee yeah man it's been a
disaster I don't know what's happening
but I can't seem to get a match to save
my life Theo Von that's rough man I hear
you but let's be real your picture on
these apps is a little well let's just
say it's not your best angle Bobby Lee
hey now that picture was taken on a good
day Theo Von laughs all right all right
so have you tried any new pickup lines
on these apps Bobby Lee oh yeah I've
tried everything I've even tried sending
pictures of my cat but still no luck
Theo Von laughs your cat huh well that's
a new one have you considered sending
pictures of food instead Bobby Lee
laughing actually that's not a bad idea
maybe I'll try that next Theo Von laughs
I think that's a solid plan Bobby you
never know you might find her soulmate
on a dating app for Foodies Bobby Lee
laughing yeah that would be a good one
swipe right if you love sushi Theo Von
laughs exactly you might just be onto
something there Bobby Bobby Lee laughing
thanks Theo I'll give it a shot who
knows maybe this will finally be my
lucky break on these dating apps okay
that that one I honestly don't think was
as good as the other two Theo ones we
just did but it's still creating a fake
conversation that sounds kind of real
what about these two random people Bobby
and Theo this is bizarre well there you
have it if you don't think about how
scary that is and how it's eventually
going to lead to the demise of all of us
that was pretty fun I had a good time
doing this we might have to make a part
two to this video let me know in the
comments what comedians you would like
to see in AI version of in part two in
general I think the job of comedians is
safe for now it's not fully there we'll
still have podcasters for at least a few
more years but that is concerning dude I
mean if you don't think about how creepy
and and scary and frightening all this
AI stuff is it can be fun this was a
completely free website called chat GPT
you can type that into your browser
right now have some fun with it yourself
thank you for watching this video we'll
be back again Monday with the comedy
news in the meantime make sure you
subscribe and like and check out our
second Channel clip world and um
have a great weekend that's the most
important part have a great weekend and
uh enjoy life while you can because the
robots are coming for us
[Music]